sometimes in Cable Dana you just say
things yeah I was just thinking
just trying to get a get a reaction yeah
is that one of those moments and there's
no consequences
should be yeah there should be you
should be able to say stupid stuff like
that I did say at least six stupid
things a day a day a segment a segment
I'm just putting it out there just put
it out there provocative Greg I have to
say that that story's about Doug mhoff
rally trying to rally the troops behind
Kamala Harris you know they they
reportedly met with rolling eyes in the
white house because
first of all I would never want my
husband to do that for me if you are not
or if people aren't already ready to
Rally around you you can't have your
husband go and fight that battle for you
I mean come on and obviously we'd have
never had a second gentleman before but
I assume that if the if the people in
The West Wing aren't taking her
seriously how seriously are they taking
him you know couples where the husband
like really like helps the wife's career
and really encourages it and like it
doesn't really take off second gentleman
sounds like the title of like a Cinemax
remember Cinemax those late night things
or maybe a romance novel with Fabio on
the cover the second gentleman I uh you
know I don't I'm more interested in how
fetterman has ruined the look of the
hoodie for me oh yeah I used to like to
wear a hoodie but then when you start
wearing it in inappropriate places it
kind of stained its beauty so that's why
I'm not voting for him for president so
good reason thank you do you want to
take on Judge the fetterman for
president line or do you want to talk
about the dude the second dude I want to
talk
Amala I mean how could
he says the woman's been giggling like
she's been laughing the whole two years
so far she hasn't said anything smart
and she just Giggles every picture
it's so disappointing for women so I
mean mhoff I don't know who he is I
don't care who he is I don't think she's
going anywhere let's talk about
betterment the guy can't get out of his
own way but it works for the Democrats
that's the point if you're not a quality
candidate on the Republican side you
don't get elected but if you're an idiot
who hides either in a trojan horse like
Joe Biden or fetterman or what's her
name Katie Hobbs you'll get elected the
best fetterman line and they were like
well do you support fracking and he's
like yes and he's like but you used to
not support fracking and he's like I
support fracking
well great candidate right
yeah in a lot of ways
if you watch the primary play out I was
supportive of Conor lamb I thought that
he was the better choice for it but what
about it what do you know what about who
lamb would have gotten crushed I don't
think I want to hear from a woman a
Democrat woman what do you think of
Kamala is she presidential material
she's vice presidential material
listen I've been very open in this
Kamala Harris was not my choice in the
primary she was not the choice of a lot
of people who were going to go and vote
which is why she dropped out and a lot
of people who were huge Hillary Clinton
supporters and it was a big issue that
didn't feel that she was
worthy of that mantle that she was a
strong a candidate as Hillary Clinton
was but what I will say is everyone
always talks about her she doesn't get
what does she do she doesn't get
anything done she's in charge of the
Border root causes blah blah blah you
know what a shoe she was in charge of
abortion you know what happened
Democrats had a 53 Point advantage on
the issue of abortion she was the one
who was out front for the administration
talking about it about the threat to
women especially in cities what a
stretch yeah you get all the credit
Kamala way to go well I'm sorry Joe but
when people talk about Joe Biden's
Legacy they talk about what happened
with same-sex marriage and he was in
charge of that of course the crimes he's
committed overseas no you do but
normally people talk about the fact that
he was answer your question what does
the second gentleman do all day
the same thing that the when a lady does
the job are you sure about that I keep
standing up that's different he doesn't
have other things going on like what
like that like a shave or something what
do you mean I just want to know what he
does all day I think this is an
exposition for prime time that's right
we're gonna look into that he's that
second gentleman what does that mean
you're not even joking I'm gonna do this